last time we looked at tls and we had a
bit of a chat about where it came from
the history and how it evolved
um so i suppose we're we're left with
the uh the idea of working out how it
works in that handshake procedure right
that's right yeah everything in tls
happens in the handshake i mean that's
not absolutely true but
you know the majority of all the
important stuff is in there
the reason that tls is so prevalent and
so used and how good it is
is all down to how good the handshake is
so let's dive right in
and see what it is that it does
underneath
today we're going to look at the tls 1.2
handshake not the tls 1.3
the reason is because i personally think
that 1.2 is
perhaps a little bit more intuitive when
you're learning it for the first time
i like to look at 1.3 you know by by way
of how it changes from 1.2 rather than
just on its own like that so
you know we can talk about 1.3 another
time before we start i just wanted to
show you if you go to your web browser i
mean
different web browsers show different
things um but
you know in firefox here i'm on the
nottingham website if i click on the
padlock and i click more information
we can see that i've got a tls session
so my computer my browser
in this case and the nottingham web
server
have formed a tls connection that sits
over tcp
and is encrypting http before it gets
sent and received
now what i'm interested in is this
string down here so we're just going to
copy that down
and then we'll talk about what that is
and then when we look at the handshake
you'll see all these different bits
appearing because basically this is what
we call a cipher suite
so this is a string representation of
all the different things we're going to
do during our handshake right so for
example key exchange
public key authentication um the actual
encryption and things like this right
they're all in there so let's have a
quick look
i'm going to bring up the um inks pad
thingy oh this is here from last time
last time we used this app yeah okay
yeah yeah this is only for recording
videos and stuff so you know
when i'm not recording videos i'm not
really using it i just use my computer
um all right so let's take this off
there were a few different cipher suites
but the one we're looking at today is
the most common one
and that is tls e c
d h e r s a
with a e s one two eight
g c m i've run out of space sha256
it was impossible to know when i started
at that font size that it wasn't going
to make it all the way to the end
right there's a lot of stuff going on
here so let's have a look at these right
so tls we know what we know what that is
right that was the whole last video
transport layer security you got two two
or three ec dhe
that's elliptic curve diffie-hellman
ephemeral right we've talked about
diffie-hell before
that is the key exchange so that is how
we
obtain some kind of shared secret that
only you and i have or only me and the
web server has
so no one else can see what we're doing
that's obviously going to be used to
derive keys for encryption
rsa this is going to be the public key
authentication mechanism
right so we're going to make sure that
that server is who they say they are by
checking a public key
certificate and verifying their
additional signature and then when we've
actually done that that's the handshake
part
then the actual encryption is going to
be happening using aes so this is the
cipher
this is the key size this is the mode of
operation so this is going to be galois
counter mode i think i might have
mentioned that in a previous
video but if i didn't it's a whole
different video and finally
sha256 we've talked about hash functions
before
is the kind of the building block that's
used to perform hash functions where
they're needed so things like turning a
secret into a key
and creating mesh authentication codes
and things
these are some things we've covered in
other videos um
so all of this is in here and we've got
only a few messages to get this done
right because it's got to be really
really quick so let's go through the
actual handshake and then we'll see some
of these things appearing
we're going to start a conversation over
the internet it's going to be with
someone using tls
so we begin obviously with a tcp
handshake to get a tcp connection
established
um and before we send any application
data that's when we're going to do our
tls handshake
so this is the client over here and this
is the server over here
i'm going with client server this time
not alice and bob it would work just as
well with alison bob if you think about
the way the web works
um we always the client is always the
one approaching the server
amazon well for the most part doesn't
just send you random websites right
you ask for a website and it gives you
one or you ask for a file and it gives
you one
so the first thing we're going to do is
send a message and that message is
called
client hello we know what that message
is because
all tls messages have a number that
identifies them and so basically you can
read off the head when you can work out
what kind of message this is now this
client hello message is going to contain
a few things first of all it's going to
contain
the max tls version that this client can
support because obviously you've got
different
servers you've got different clients so
it's going to be the max tls version
that they support
not every server and every client is
exactly the same they won't all support
the very very latest version so they
maybe don't support 1.3
so maybe they send 1.2 but that's the
maximum version they support
they're going to send a random number
and that's used to make sure that replay
attacks for example
aren't going to work and finally they're
going to send
a list of cipher suites so
that cypher suite we looked at just
before there's going to be a number of
those that they support
probably and they're going to send a
list of all the votes each of them has a
number so it's
a nice short list assuming the server is
switched on
right that's a whole different problem
right so i'll have that out right so
we've got the client hello
so at this point the server knows what
the client can do
and now it has to pick something right
the way that tls does it is that the
server is the one that actually chooses
as a client you go to the server and you
say i can do these things
and it says right we're going to use
that one so the server
is going to respond with a server hello
now that's going to contain very similar
things to what the client hello contains
so it's going to have
a chosen tls version right so let's say
the client supported 1.3
but the server only supports 1.2 it will
send back 1.2
it's going to choose one of the cypher
suites and usually it will have some
kind of configuration
and which ones it prefers and things
like this and then it's going to also
send a random number
um if if the server doesn't support any
of the versions or the cypher suites
that the client does which is very
unusual then obviously this is not going
to work they're going to send back some
kind of failure message
right they're actually sending back a
tls alert and that that will say yeah
it's not going to work
right we won't be having a conversation
all right so this is the beginning of
the handshake we now know
what we're going to do we're going to
use let's say elliptic curve
diffie-hellman we're going to use rsa
we're going to use aes when we
eventually get to encryption
so now we actually have to do those
things unfortunately so the server is
going to send another message
and this is going to be a certificate
various videos have talked about public
key certificates before
but this is just going to be a standard
format certificate with an rsa key if
that's what we've agreed to
use and it's going to crucially have a
public key on it right so this is going
to have
a public key attached to it the server
is then going to send what we call the
server
key exchange message that has a few
things in it
right the first thing it has is the
parameters
for the diffie-hellman key exchange
right so we talked about the parameters
g
n back way back when we did the video
alice and bob have to agree some
mathematical parameters that they're
going to use
this is a value g or a generator and a
big
prime number n right now for this it's
going to choose some of those
possibly elliptic curve ones probably
because that's what we're using and it's
also going to send its
public part it's public message as part
of that key exchange process
so if you remember back very briefly in
diffie hellman
you each send a public value across and
then you
you combine it with some private values
behind the scenes this is all the
colored water video we did that's the
color water video yeah which but kind of
works yeah
the server keeps change also very
importantly has a digital signature as
part of it so i'm going to write that in
quick digital
signature now a digital signature
is essentially a set of these previous
messages
summarized using a hash function and
signed using the private key of the
server the one that goes with the public
key that's on the certificate
it's the proof that the server is who
they say they are because only
theoretically that server has the
private key
right we've covered these kind of things
before and different i think rob did a
video on public key
the fact that it can be decrypted with
your public key
means that it must have been encrypted
with your private key which means it
must have been you
who made the message because only you
have your private key what the client's
going to do is it's going to look at the
certificate it's going to verify that
that's okay
and then it's going to look at the
digital signature and verify that's okay
using the certificate
and if they're both okay as a client we
can be pretty happy
that the server is who they say they are
right this is almost for me the most
important message
right because if you can't establish
that the server is who they say they are
then this courses could be a complete
imposter
and then we've got a real problem so
there's also the video that richard
morty did on
secure web where he talked about you
follow this chain of trust all the way
up to a certification authority that's
the process that this client is going to
follow
so at this point the server sent their
part of the key exchange they send their
digital signature and certificate so
they verify themselves
their job for now is over right so
they're going to send
a server hello
done and that says i'm not sending you
any more weird information right you've
got everything you need like if you're
not happy that's
unfortunately just how it's going to be
so
it's now in the clients it's now the
client's turn right
so the client as you remember
in the key exchange you've both got to
send something right so the client is
going to reply
with a client key
exchange now normally the client doesn't
send a certificate
they don't have to send a certificate
verification or anything like this a
signature
and they of course already have the
parameters but the server sent so all
they're going to send is they're like
alice public value
right that the one that goes in uh over
here these can be used mathematically as
part of the diffie-hellman process
to create what we call a pre-master
secret so at this at this point
the server and the client both have the
same pre-master secret
right they combine that pre-mastered
secret with the random numbers from
above
and that becomes the master secret right
and that's the one that's used to derive
any kind of key material
that's going to be used during this
process this is looking kind of
complicated but actually we're nearly
finished right this is this doesn't take
a very long time
the client is now going to send a
change sign for spec message what the
change cypher spec message says
is i've got all the information i need
from our previous handshake
i'm actually ready to begin encryption
so the next message you see from me
is going to be encrypted right using all
this using aes
128-bit key galore counter mode using
the key that we just derived and so on
so they're then going to send a finished
message
and that finished message is going to
contain a summary
of all of the messages so far encrypted
like using the key right so obviously if
this process has failed the server's not
going to be able to decrypt it the
server is going to respond with the
exact same thing so they're going to
send over this way
a change cipher spec and then a finished
message which will be encrypted
now the really important thing about
these finished messages which didn't
usually exist in the really early
versions of ssl
is that they summarize all the messages
you've seen so far so imagine someone
was sitting in the middle tampering with
the messages
maybe they tricked the server into
thinking the client actually only
supported 1.1
right well then the client and the
server are going to have seen different
versions of events
and that means that these two finished
messages aren't going to match so if
they don't match
bail bail from the conversation jump out
the nearest window right it's not good
times
let's look back at what we wanted from
this and work out where we got it
right um so we wanted some kind of
shared secret right because if we didn't
have a shared secret
we're not going to be able to do any
kind of encryption this is where we have
the
server key exchange message and the
client key exchange message
which contain those diffie-hellman uh
parameters that we're gonna
we're gonna share then we need to have
some kind of authentication if not of
the client then at least of the server
right that's the way
we normally do on the web it's it's you
know it's fairly common to authenticate
the client as well
you know in other other situations this
is going to be the digital signature
and the certificate that do this so
that's rsa
it doesn't have to be rsa but that's you
know what we're using this example
we needed to originally agree on what we
were going to do right we need you know
some kind of
uh what what messages we're going to
send right that's all defined in the
spec
and of course that was part of the
client hello and the server hello which
had all that information on which side
of the suite we're going to use and
finally we wanted to make sure that
there wasn't someone tampering with this
it wasn't a replay attack
we wanted to make sure that someone
hadn't fiddled with the messages that's
what the finished message is uh
green green i've run out this is what
i've got quite a lot of colors compared
to my felt tip pens
right that's what the finished messages
is doing right the finished messages
are making sure that now is tampered
with the messages and also
the random numbers for part of the
client and the server hellos also
prevent things like replay attacks they
make sure that the key material is
different every time
and so on and so forth um so
this is this has everything we want
right it's very very difficult to break
into this
you know if i want to a better phrase um
and the other thing to know
is that we've gone once from the client
to the server
and then we've gone back from these
messages are usually sent basically in
the same packet i said or very close
together
back from the server to the client back
to the server back to the client and
then we're ready to go
so it's two round trips right so if you
if you live 200 milliseconds away
in terms of you know transmission time
from
the server this is going to take 400
just under half a second basically to do
this which is what happens when you go
to a website
when you connect to we type in the url
it'll do a dns lookup
if it hasn't been already cached and
then you'll just do this very quick tls
handshake
and then encrypt everything right so
it's really really quick
tls 1.3 does this in just one round trip
right so they've sped it up even faster
how many times would this happen is this
something that gets refreshed every now
and then
is this for the entire session of your
time browsing that website
yeah it's going to depend on um on you
know a few different things
usually you would set up a tls
connection
and then you would go off to let's say
for an index.html page and then
images that you download will also have
use the same
connection right you wouldn't do a tls
handshake for every different resource
but then if you if you know you browse
away from the website and come back that
would likely be a new
exchange right there is kind of session
resumption and stuff that
will sometimes be implemented on a
server level that will depend on the
configuration of the server
you i guess you could imagine if you're
a server sending out hundreds of
thousands of these
being able to resume sessions when it's
safe to do so
kind of makes sense right from a sort of
computation point of view
you know verifying certificates of
things does take a little bit of time
i guess if um if there's ad servers
involved they will be separate
connections there yeah if you go off to
another server to get a resource whether
it's an ad or something else
that's going to be a different tls
connection sometimes you get one of
those warnings where only part of your
session is encrypted that's because
you've got an https
or tls session set up but one of the
resources you're fetching out is not
https so that's unencrypted
right that's just bad website
programming to do that if you stay on a
website for a long time
then keys or this session will be
refreshed every so half an hour or
something like that to make sure that
you've got new keys
new keyword too and you've got that
perfect forward secrecy you said it um
1.3 is even faster i mean is has
everybody moved to 1.3 or
is that relatively new no not at all i
mean we just went on the nottingham
website and they're
they're supporting 1.2 right and i'm not
singling them out loads of people are
still supporting 1.2
perhaps one of the differences so 1.0
and 1.1 have now been deprecated
officially so we're not supposed to use
them
um but unlike those 1.2 is actually
still pretty good right and if you
configure it it's basically the same as
1.3 just a little bit slower with the
handshake
it doesn't support quite as many
different things really what 1.3 did
is obviously a faster handshake and it
locked down a lot of the cypher sweeps
you can use and things like this
if you're only using those cypher sweeps
anyway 1.2 is not that big a deal
it involves you know reinstallation of a
lot of server software
people are just being a little bit slow
but it's not it's not a huge problem
right most browsers now support 1.3 so
if you go to a website that supports it
you'll be able to find one
carry on copying for another 65 528
worth of bytes
now where those extra bytes going to
come from or they're going to come from
whatever follows on in memory in the
computer's memory that's there if we're
lucky
that data will be meaningless so it's
still just you claiming to be whoever
you claim to be
and i've got no other way of checking
that out which is why a lot of browsers